[Musique]
capitaine fantastique donc c'est un film
de Matros qui est sorti en 2016 ici
c'est un film où le héros est humain on
ne parle pas d'un super-héros comme
Batman comme Superman ou Iron Man mais
ici l'humain à part entière est un héros
au sens naturel on va glorifier la
différence des humains des humains qui
vivent dans la forêt et des humains qui
vivent en ville Vico Mortensen donc le
père de la famille va élever donc ses
enfants et sa femme dans la forêt et va
devoir faire face en fait à la ville au
cours d'une tragique histoire ici du
coup on va faire face à des enfants qui
ne connaissent rien à la ville rien en
l'amour rien à sociabilité des gens et
du coup on va voir des scènes d'humour
todrome des fois malaisant et des fois
un peu plus tragique du coup on est
vraiment sur le cœur ils ont des
hot-dogs
un moment on a des enfants qui parlent
également de l'amendement de la
Constitution des États-Unis qui la
connaissent par cœur face à des enfants
qui sortent du bac qui ne connaissent
rien du tout ça qui est assez drôle on
est vraiment sur des propos très simples
c'est un film qui a du corps de la
volonté du cœur et on peut vraiment
parler du sens de la famille
[Musique]